l'automne a été marquée par de vives
tensions en nouvelle écosse au coeur du
conflit l'accès au homard pour les
pêcheurs autochtones et non autochtones
cette pêche rapporte groupe c'est
d'ailleurs la plus lucrative en
atlantique
alors que se passe-t-il au juste et
quelles pourraient être les impacts pour
les pêcheurs et les crustacés
[Musique]
c'était une première en nouvelle écosse
[Applaudissements]
le 17 septembre une communauté micmaque
du sud ouest de la province a lancé une
pêche au homard autogéré quelques
semaines avant le début de la saison
régulière de pêche commerciale
les autochtones ont mis à l'eau quelques
centaine de casiers à homard dans la
baie sainte-marie
c'est l'un des endroits où ce crustacé
est le plus abondant en nouvelle écosse
même si les pêcheurs commerciaux possède
dans le secteur des dizaines de milliers
de casiers à homards
l'initiative a mis le feu aux poudres on
a senti que l'ambiance était explosive
ya des centaines de pêcheurs autochtones
et non autochtones qui se sont affrontés
ici sur le quai là où on se trouve ce
soir dans les jours qui suivent deux
vivier à omar sont saccagés l'un d'eux
est incendié tout comme une fourgonnette
et un bateau
[Musique]
les autochtones soutiennent qu'ils ont
le droit de pêcher à l'ani et de vendre
le produit de leur pêche en vertu de
traités ancestraux en 1999 la cour
suprême du canada leur a d'ailleurs
donné raison
cette année là le plus haut tribunal du
pays a rendu un jugement connu sous le
nom d' arrêt marshall donald marshall un
pêcheur mic mac et est accusé entre
autres d'avoir pêché hors saison et
d'avoir vendu au noir près de 200 kg
d'anguilles avec l'arrêt marshall la
cour confirme que 34 premières nations
de la région ont le droit à la chasse la
pêche et la cueillette pour s'assurer
d'une subsistance convenable ou modéré
le tribunal se base sur des traités de
paix et d'amitié signé dans les années
1700 par contre le gouvernement pourrait
intervenir dans le cas notamment où la
ressource serait menacée le hic c'est
que la cour n'a pas défini ce qui était
une subsistance convenable de combien
les autochtones ont ils besoin pour
vivre convenablement
de 30 50 70 mille dollars personne n'est
jamais arrivé à répondre à cette
question
jean leclerc et spécialiste de droit
constitutionnel la cour prend soin de
dire que par subsistance convenable on
entend subsistance convenable pas en
1761 maintenant à partir de là c'est le
problème c'est que il ya une dimension
politique
la cour suprême est composée de juges
nos élus elle n'a pas le pouvoir décrire
les lois cette tâche revient au
gouvernement fédéral dans ce cas ci
puisqu'il est question de pêcheries et
d'affaires autochtones
la courbe post m a donné des détails
elle n'a aucune
expert compétences dans la gestion des
ressources halieutiques et donc ce
qu'elle dit c'est qu'il ya dix mois ma
fonction s'il vous dit que les
autochtones ont un droit constitutionnel
et leurs droits
c'est un droit de commercer à des fins
de subsistance pour le reste battez vous
entourent depuis 21 ans un flou persiste
donc selon les lois de la nouvelle
écosse les usines de transformation ne
peuvent acheter que le homard pêcher
avec un permis de pêche et océans canada
permis que les autochtones n'ont pas
encore obtenu pour la pêche de
subsistance convenable
[Musique]
pour les pêcheurs non autochtone qui
respecte les saisons définies par le
gouvernement
cette pêche hors saison n'est rien moins
qu illégale et elle fait craindre un
effet domino multipliant par exemple
indice sous-jacent en 2000
l'effort de pêche actuelle et il en
commet souvent ces problèmes une pêche
qui n'est pas une règlement d'ivoire
manille un désastre écologique
on voit ici de les stocks dormants ou 10
minutes beaucoup dans les données de
trois ans ça va commencer à te problème
pis pour l'instant c'est un problème qui
est localisée mais c'est juste qu'il se
tend avec ça soit partout la canada
atlantique lyon même si les autochtones
se sont dotés d'un plan de pêche durable
les pêcheurs commerciaux insiste une
pêche hors saison menace la conservation
de la ressource
mais ont-ils raison de s'inquiéter des
biologistes comme aaron meknes ont pris
position dans le dossier
quelques centaine de casiers de plus ne
met pas les stocks de homard en péril
je suis très confiant par rapport au
stock dormard en nouvelle-écosse c'est
une ressource abondante qui rapporte
plus d'un milliard de dollars à
l'économie de la province
chaque année mais si le homard se
portent en général très bien la prudence
serait peut être de mise dans la baie
sainte-marie précisément là où a lieu le
conflit depuis 2016 les prises et ont
diminué de 46%
dans la baie sainte-marie il y a trois
types de pêche une pêche commerciale à
laquelle participent des pêcheurs d'un
autochtone et aussi quelques autochtones
cette pêche de subsistance récemment
lancé par les micmacs il y aussi une
autre page à laquelle les premières
nations ont droit une pêche alimentaire
sociale et rituels le produit de cette
pêche qui est destiné à nourrir les
communautés ne peut pas être vendu mais
cette règle n'est pas toujours respectée
ce qui suscite la colère des pêcheurs
commerciaux
l'inquiétude des pêcheurs non autochtone
c'est qu'il y aurait selon eux des
milliers de kazimiya l'eau dans cette
baie c'est ça qui a nourri la tension
les cinq sens quasi la nouvelle pêche de
subsistance convenable ont été
l'étincelle qui a déclenché le conflit
le faux pêche est toujours recchi études
pour les biologistes et pour les
gestions des cantons prennent le risque
y est un collègue d'armé tenir à
l'université dalhousie
il rappelle que contrairement à certains
poissons le homard n'est pas un grand
migrateur le coin plus important ici il
le fait que les aubois ne se déplace pas
beaucoup donc dans ce petit pays comme
la celui-ci
une fois que tu commences ton monte et
le nombre des permis l'ombre des pièges
à howard
on va commencer d'enlever toutes les
jaunards est à ce point là il y à la
grande inconnue
le braconnage en entrevue avec notre
collègue de moncton nicola steinbach
l'ancien ministre de pêches et océans
robert thibault qui habite au bord de la
baie sainte marie dénonce une pêche
illicite qui prend de l'ampleur selon
lui dans les deux trois dernières années
c'est devenu un échelle industrielle
c'est devenu un braconnage organisé ou
des gens de la communauté acadienne
accueil hors crottes des grandes
communautés amérindiennes et cette pêche
illicite a lieu en été un moment crucial
pour le renouvellement de l'espèce
c'est la période de mue et de
reproduction pour le homard
ici le moment où il est le plus affamé
il devient donc plus faciles à capturer
pour rétablir la confiance et espérer
sortir de cette impasse des données
claires et fiables seront primordiales
il va falloir qu'on se mette d'accord
sur des faits combien de homard pêche au
thon combien y en at il dans cette ville
ce sera la base de la négociation et une
semaine plusieurs sont d'avis qu'il ya
de la place pour les
autochtone et les autochtones dans la
pêche l'enjeu c'est de déterminer qui a
droit à quoi
depuis l'arrêt machaoud certaines
négociations ont porté fruit mais il
reste encore beaucoup de pain sur la
planche
les autochtones il commence à gagner des
causes est la leur niveau d'impatience à
l'égard de les inégalités qui reste
devient de plus en plus intense et on
moi je le sens chez les jeunes acteurs
c'est une chose qu'il faut garder en
tête il va y avoir moins de patience du
couteau cteur
et peu importe l'issue des négociations
dans le bien de tous il faudra faire de
la pérennité de la ressource
une priorité
[Musique]